et bien bonjour peuple de youtube et
bienvenue dans ce cinquième et avant
dernier épisode de notre les spéciaux à
haute classe 2 on commence dit avec mike
souvenez vous en citer fait enterrer
dans un [ __ ] de cercueils géo verve
sortir de là et là il va pousser
au hockey leur butin ok mec là pour
hâter les conneries parce qu'ils vont
essayer de revenir vite faut qu'on se
casse boîtes de haut non il ya encore
lui [ __ ] de truc qui rend et qui est
envers moi il rentre juste qu'il soit de
ramper puisqu'il envie de remplacer sa
passion gens remplis comme ça je sais
pas mais je propose qu'on se casse
à mon avis c'est pas ici je le sens bien
le regard des fougères là-bas tout droit
il a souvent tendance à toi de chemin
comme ça waouh il ya des il ya des
petites créatures partout mec ait tué
les deux rampes en asie allons jeter un
oeil aux torontois
[ __ ] j'ai un bandage
il ya chez un bandage même bord des
hoquets nickel alors il ya une page la
prend en photo et je me casse
[Applaudissements]
il ya des bruits les débris d'un mec
bons mecs savent où l'on bat les
couilles chacun pour sa gueule
ouais à bientôt entendu il est mort
envoyées à la même famille était venue
des foutus up [ __ ] nickel un homme
pendu elle s'est pendue avant que je
puisse l'en empêcher wen s'est pas non
attends pas l île
ah ouais ok est leur modèle faire un
quiproquo avec jesse sa pote tu déconnes
l'axé pan du verger m'en sers plus sur
salat qui s'est passé et pourquoi elle a
conduit cette meuf
bon alors je sois juste pas me reprendre
des flèches mec de l'arche est trop
chaud de la voix ok alors on laisse
porter comment je fais pour des sangles
à un mec je pense faire le grand saut à
lanrelas par là j'aurais dû faire le
grand plongeon
il n'y a pas de panique à bord on est
bien désolé j'ai pu prendre
j'ai dû prendre accord de cette poule i
parce que je voulais monter au ciel rats
[ __ ] vous ne décrochez lapointe que
j'aime dans ce canard besoin ok alors tu
es ou mec qui appelle à cordes abc le
mexicain cemex est ok par là je suis un
petit peu que ça vaut évidemment
tha bon mais qu'à un moment le micro
avec s'achète faut y aller et je parle
pas de lévis machete trucks
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
r tu accordes frère tu accordes dame est
fomentée faut remonter je trop con je
trouve qu'on pollue se monte à l'éco
petit plus je dois te racheter la gueule
ok maintenant faut que j'aille là-bas
sauf que ça fait du bruit vont griller
sa cinq espaces sauvegarde savons pas
pourquoi on commence à connaître la
sauvegarde
je peux à l'espérer moi j'y crois de
tout mon coeur fou secourir enfin ce
prix de mon pote
merci merci de ta de pendu vraiment ça
me fait super plaisir
mais non mais non seulement au québec
ces moments medco au mollet mais qui
vole tellement pas au nom mais là par
contre mexes et fut des flèches c'est
des mecs mais que c'est plus des flèches
qui lancent ces des tire dessus avec un
avec une ak47 là
[Musique]
oh oui presque odiet tient héros des
photos plutôt le mexique caché dans un
arbre près jusqu'où réponse paraît loin
quoi j'en peux plus le voir à lui a vu
petit là sur sa monture là un groupe
vraiment à lens qu'un ça va craquer ce
qu'il aime le moins champion du monde
[Applaudissements]
mais non plus 12 h salle
ok moi je cachais avantage on est déjà
qu'un chef
on est bien vous signez vous avez besoin
de bandages je je je vois je vois bien
jouer bien aujourd'hui je vois bien
c'est un mec
le fait est que j'en ai pas intérêt à
questionner ses pardons hockey une
trappe
oh non mais on est où là
si je pourrais le retour à l'école dans
soit ça non c'est vraiment la neige d'un
coup nancy c'est honteux c'est une
vision ça c'est l'école
j'entends des bruits de pas mec je
prenne pas retourné je refuse de me
retourner au sa mère elle était là non
non mais là ça va
l'homme sauté dessus je le sais je le
sens c'est par où apparemment pas pour
moi c'est le toit de l'école ça c'est ça
dès lors elle s'est pendue peut-être
chebah vous y allez pas où c'est par là
ça se referme sans foi l on y va on y va
avant ça on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas
le temps et jean-michel pas le temps il
faut y aller vous signez vous avez
besoin de bandage mais franchement je te
jure j'ai puisque le bund what the fuck
c'est quoi y avait de ma faim tu as mais
vous poser la question et avoir moins de
ma faim ouattara
je voulais mourir leur vote il ya trois
colonnes pardon au syndrome ouf
opus aujourd'hui j'ai pas beaucoup dormi
cette nuit du coup je suis hypersensible
désolé pardon juste c'est-à-dire de
vocal elles montrent un elle montre bel
et bien
ah ben je suis entre les deux non toi tu
es une vision toi la théorie du qu elle
est en bas on remontait stp en eau et du
coup on peut aller de là d'où elle vient
en fait c'est là bas qu'il faut aller
c'est ici en bacs faudra aller à mon
avis ça le délire ok voilà on redescend
parce qu'elle est là
là du coup elle est plus là voilà c'est
ça on n'est bien sûr pas par la spa au
hockey faut que je me casse on se tire
moi comme ça déforme images des isbas
buzzé sur les faits j'en ai fait windows
movie maker tu sais à celle là ouais ok
super beau ok ok mais non ok j'ai cru
qu'il ya quelqu'un parce que je suis le
maire sauvegarde
j'étais jaloux tu était quelqu'un de
payer quoi j'ai à gauche là y'a quoi y'a
quoi bon je me casse bonbons tout un
tapage travaille à mon avis un truc à
moi je n'ai pas vu cette europe qu'au
placebo
on est bien on n'est pas bien là mais
ultra bien moins chez nous à [ __ ] là
on est moins bien d'un coup quand les
portes s'ouvrent plus thibault alors on
est bien l'abordage finalement envoyé
comme on est bien c'est tellement de
rebondissements cet épisode c'est
incroyable ah [ __ ] j'ai des vautours
ici j'en peux plus
à kano zizanie morts ayhan note des ntl
tmg
ok voilà
d'accord pour joindre la croix j'arrive
ges
elle est partie la merde
oh non [ __ ] tu mon temps on va tomber
nez à nez sur un monstre je vous le dis
c'était une évidence est plus là bon tu
as le mec qui est un vrai traumatisme
quoi en même temps tu as une pote qui se
pend à l'école mais que le bon gros bad
quoi je peux mon père j'ai pas le droit
de monter et je peux monter peut-être je
pas le droit de monter bond à 6 par la
up
[ __ ] je veux recommencer [ __ ] de
trouver j'espère juste pour avoir le mec
sur sa monture franchement il me fout le
cafard
je mangeais pas envie tour et d'épisodes
si à cause de lui ok ça marche on fait
ça en fait comme ça on dit que c'est un
bon plan on y va on espère dans la forêt
[Applaudissements]
mais non nous n'allons pas mettre un
[ __ ] de retailles dans ses toiles
pourquoi des choses qui clochent je
cachais dans l'autre dans les fougères a
rarement à verneuil noir mais aussi on
va aller voir laquelle il a dit un truc
cloche c'est ce vers quoi les enquêtés
brasier mais croyez-le ou non mais un
moment va pas chipoter on va pas on va
dans lan via les uns on agit on va voir
ce qui se passe non halal
non mais le mec comme dans l'eau je vais
pas mettre un [ __ ] d'orteils dans
cette eau quelque chose que jouer avec
cela que j'avais pas vu que un mec qui
était rentré calmement dans l'eau sinon
effectivement j'aurais peut-être changer
d'avis bah du coup faut passer par la
gauche par la droite par la droite par
la droite
on y va on va demander des mails moi
j'aimerais retrouver des piles on va se
faire petit à ba voila il ya une pile
c'est sûr
ce bruit et un bruit de sonnette la cua
photo cl et puis ça grâce de partout mon
pote ça abusé vous permet carrément l on
y va à la mano
fortin
s'écrie très peu cordiale qui est
quel bordel
quel bordel salama c'est au c'est vrai
c'est quoi ça une tour une tour radio
une liaison et retiennent la
civilisation peut-être ou alors est
assez stupide pour penser que ça sauve
c'est un asile de théza tôt c'est la za
au delà saint-sever maroc et une rave
comme ça ça ce serait drôle ah [ __ ]
dans sa non ça c'est beaucoup moins
drôle ça vraiment d'un coup il n'y a
plus aucun foyer les zygomatiques
inactifs immédiatement face à ça faut
que je saute attend ça c'est lumière
normale ou c'est le petit avec sa
monture là c'est moi j'ai un atout
depuis l'épisode une ancienne flamme
c'est bon j'ai bien par à domec
c'est par là ok dans le milieu comme ça
va on a vu pire dans la fosse au thé
hockey
attention je m'élance
ah mon dieu à sauvegarde non
il fait tellement noir je le sens pas je
peux pas vous le dire
ouais
ok ok son parti on se bat pour quoi ils
sont partis en courant
ces deux mais encore moins en confiance
que s'il était vraiment la cua et note
là elles sont parties pour me faire peur
en fait mais avec moi je suis passé par
l'eau bon c'est quoi ça et un autre là
dedans faut que j'aille
c'est quoi ce truc spécial janvier
mediapart mmorpg est pour dire à papa
que note que les horreurs et le tourment
qui se trouvent ici mais à l'épreuve ma
foi en dieu l'homme seul ne peut pas dû
faire face l'ennemi attend les ténèbres
que de sauver mon âme est la vôtre je te
remercie pour ces doux mots me donnant
vraiment très très peu de courage il y
avait dans cette maison pas on va pas on
meurt à dos je peux le traversier avec
ça oui mais ça c'est une très très bonne
idée mais quelle idée excellente
enfin on navigue en iran à naviguer
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de longer le bord on peut pas
y ait un petit barrage la bombe
2paq ans le phare
oh ça tu es tout les fiches pardon c'est
sur les signes l'apocalypse
j'espère que c'est juste perdu la raison
e
tu as perdu tu auras dolla surtout moi
très franc avec toi
non
mais les chiens lui l'a battue même
allure à dolo ado est le radeau
oliech on m'a fait aller à leweb dans le
besoin mais classe prat et jean mallot
[ __ ] c'est bon à l'évasion va y aller
on va attendre cet endroit au ce [ __ ]
j'ai pété monrad aulas est du stadium à
faire mon gars selon les biens si
courant ça nous met bien au quai
voltaire chante on peut le faire on
chante on peut y arriver on navigue on
est un vrai pilote mon gars un vrai
capitaine des mères il est tellement mal
ou là où un trou but est là ou là on va
se coucher
voilà et qui tu roules à huit bateaux du
pasa
[Applaudissements]
oh [ __ ] c'était le hockey la pâte
papa c'est une balade là j'ai passé
presque mon gars c'est presqu'une way
était intouchable sur l'eau mon pote
intouchable à septembre ses remords
[Applaudissements]
monsieur patrick lemaire
mais les eaux les hérétiques
faire aussi pour voir qui a pas de bébé
les jarrets quoi y'a un mec là ah oui en
parler avec mais il est bien mort bien
maman cette fois c'était quoi ça hop tu
as un mec qui viennent de jeter un long
cadavres c'est vous excusez moi pardon
pardon pardon c'est en plein milieu du
chemin aquatique je peux me permettre
wallah toi je sais que tu non je veux
jouer cette vidéo je cette vidéo elle
importante est encore flou tant que
j'aurai pu marcher à la surface sur leur
dos c'est presque drôle c'est comme ça
qu'on peut marcher sur l'eau d'accord
merci vous êtes avec d'autres mecs c'est
presque drôle jaurès gars drôle dans 2
le fait de voir des cadavres flottaient
mais bon si tu veux ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah
les mecs à il faut des rollers
apparemment il trouva le p ça fait ça
m'a fait du bien de battre mal fait pour
une fois [ __ ] oh là là oh mon dieu
bontemps kizomba d'arcs et de flèches
comme le petit à la monture mais qu on
se porte bien voilà holla holla holla
holla il ya du courant tv
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait exprès c'est fait exprès je
les ai plus tard j'ai dit qu'elle a game
c'est fait exprès allez là là ça
commence à faire
merde le radeau ah bah c'est toujours là
bas au fait au bout on va les voir au
réal à pied jc je trouve ça commence à
faire long là le il ya eu très peu de
cinématiques très peu d'avancement dans
l'histoire et c'est vraiment joué au
chat et à la souris à chaque fois là et
je pense que enfin j'espère qu'on va
rapidement arriver devant ligne et tout
ou alors rapidement leurs avants ils ont
dû passer et là bas ma part la mecque
impasse maintien
j'aimerais savoir plus sur ce qui s'est
passé avec jesse ou sur ce qui s'est
passé avec l'hymne enfin ouzou ce qui se
passe actuellement avec lui et je pense
qu'on va bientôt avoir l'une de ces deux
réponses de 3 hier chez piste [ __ ] avant
la mecque
tu es content qu avertissement en tant
que bienvenus
nous sommes tous et bienvenue une
étrange manière de dire bienvenue quand
même un ya mieux comme un accueil je
trouve à a
[Applaudissements]
domec grosse cote on y va on y va ce
parti
[Applaudissements]
ok
ok ok ok c'est un grand oui sauvegarde
c'est un grand nom l'homme cet esprit
l'amour nous a libérés le mec quel amour
abordage suis très mauvais signe un
pendu de plus c'était un mauvais signe
alors il ya tous les policiers qui sont
là le sauvegarde le pendu le bandage
tout est là et ben voilà
ok faut que je me casse j'ai compris je
courais je confie j'ai morado jurado
jurado allez go go go go go go go go go
gadget au radeau
[Applaudissements]
tu as les mecs bon ben là ya du courant
de quelque chose caf
[Applaudissements]
sipa ce bruit s'est construit
oh
s'amenant
il ya du feu il manque toutes les
flèches sont les desert oasis pasqua il
m'a dit non c'est le pire c'est que vous
arrivez au nom c'est bon versailles
adacore bon j'ai perdu un bâton
il nous en reste 3 va apporter quoi
[Musique]
envoi de fuck
au document le mec il est blessé pour
agir
non pas les langues j'en ai marre de
cette langue qui me soit je me soigne
parce que là et être autant sur l'écran
alors qu'est ce qu'on va ici danois
thomas la voile je crois
d'avoir une échelle on est dans une
piscine et une échelle quelques pas
sébastien
hop là [ __ ] on se démerde ouais c'est
ça fait genre t'es pas là alors tu étais
là on t'a vu on t'a vu
[ __ ] projet retrouve une officine
bordé c'est par là tu as les excite ça
me parait que c'est frustrant dégâts
marie excitant ça veut pas ah et ben la
voilà ça confirme la règle puisque c est
plus sympa de vivre et plus tard
pourquoi j'en ai assez vu c'est bon
c'est bon les toilettes encense aussi
sans moi c'est vraiment son rebond sur
fermé c'est bloquer le départ t'es où
t'es où il était passé
elle m'a fait peur mais quand j'ai froid
t'es où il faudra qu'il faut que tu
apprennes à m'attendre
mashal ah ça c'est pas bon du tout
ok
hu allait faire
mais non ah bah ouais gros tu te rases
hockey à une page no line is war and
line belle tentative de communication
avec moi j'admire au j'admire cette pile
aussi j'ai des grands formats je l'avais
nerfs janet joueurs géniaux mais moi
j'avais l'air bon du coup faut aller de
la là où il y avait le monstre je
suppose c'est toujours ça ouais c'est
exactement ce qui se passe très belle
piscine en passant très très mal but
c'est vraiment de qualité un
établissement de qualité recommandé je
finirai jamais cette phrase si vous me
posez la question je finirai jamais
cette phrase j'aime pas quand ça
clignote [ __ ] t'es où t'es où théo à
cannes a few et you wait for me yassi 6
à 6,6 à y assure you
c'est où j'étais au hockey en tout cas
faire la même chose qu'à pousser en tout
cas non
mais pour aller buzzer il est là et
c'est assez quoi elle se faisait traqués
au bahut c'était c'est quoi le truc quoi
je parle et elle se faisait craquer au
bail il ya d'ailleurs un truc du genre
sans déconner elle n'a pas dire non
laissez moi laissez moi laissez moi un
truc qui n'allait pas vraiment d'être
persécuté par quelqu'un ou non pas un
groupe beaucoup plus du sens michael ça
ça c'est vraiment pas la fin du monde
connaît tout du sang c'est vraiment pas
l'apocalypse
[Musique]
vous
or la petite bulle on la voulait on est
déçu on arrive aux mines là on arrive
aux mines là
[Musique]
mais plus de sang qui coulait de ses
chaussures
non
j'ai juste
j'évitais de marché dans le son
d'acorn puissant qui coulait de ses
chaussures elle s'est pendue et elle
saigne et donc ça coulait de chaussures
et tapage sais pas je au [ __ ] mais
pour arrêter ça l'effet de tous comme ça
attaché
on chante là on est proche en tout cas
de savoir ce qui est arrivé à jesse son
petit lot on l'avait passé une semaine
en europe
je suis mort c'est l'ensemble
parfois les eaux je fais quoi là [ __ ]
sable à yann barthes le guen des forces
mike est tombé à mumbai coutras a
jusqu'à maintenant de le voir on n'a pas
le temps à perdre dans cet endroit
endroit tamisée mais très très loin
d'être posée
commander si elecam et celle des cadaves
partout mais que tu vois 3 pts et des
hommes
[ __ ] lettres rouges et on va tomber
sur un simple regardez regardez les
chaînes bouche sans raison on va tomber
sur un sale truc mon pote aujourd'hui
elle est une chance de ruutu et nous
devons partir fouilla les attends moi
dommage on va le recroiser mort et ça
nous fait mal tonnes dès qu'on s'est
fait un ami dans le jeu il est mort je
vous assure pas [ __ ] retour à l'école
waouh
encore un projet et un délire non
seulement avec le cours de cette fois
mais arrête je sais que tu as envie de
souffler bacon
oh non ok on à la bibliothèque la sueur
moines puis de l'autre côté j'ai le
flare pensée chose et bim bandage
incroyable
bon on sent la librairie n'ont pas
j'ai même pas vu s'est passée vous savez
la vraiment effrayant pour bloquer cette
porte merde à rbc qu'elle mais il ya un
seul pc qu'à lui mais [ __ ] je n'ai pas
vu autant pour moi bus car je reste
jusqu'à tes lahesalu ça marche c'est
bizarre je te voyais un ordinateur
tourne toi
[Musique]
ok est ce que maintenant j'ai la
permission de partir [ __ ] de juin
c'est l'enfer moyen du coup il ya times
et qui s'allume et là dedans j'ai de
l'argent une place à chaque fois c'est
ça assure l'arrière des saluts mais je
peux te voir c'était quoi sur ton écran
la feuille tu vas fermer tout à l'heure
rien je bidouille
je ne sais toujours pas trop comment cet
ordinateur fonctionne je peux t'aider
quand tu veux
lynch fait coucou à temps cloutier
soutien espoirs aprilia pour catholique
des prix mais anxieux
mon mari dit que tout arrive pour une
raison et que dure un plan mais j'ai
également qu'il faut créer sa propre
chance tu fais quelque chose tu dois
changer ce qui entraîne un changement
pour y arriver je ne peux pas lui dire
qu il se contredit
parce qu'il n'aime pas ça elle peut
avoir la main lourde gersois n'avoir
aucun contrôle et que tout est ma faute
en même temps j'ai le pire des deux
mondes et jesse qui répond à ça j'ai
parfois la même sensation souvent tu es
un adulte d'accord au ca fois beau et et
flipper à la porte ouverte incroyable
non non je sens qu'elle va paraître je
chantonne pour me rassurer
et voilà
[Musique]
jess a est pas loin elle est pas loin on
l'entend à quand on trouve rt galles
rentrée il ya un truc à voir et oui
c'est un pan du encore hlm
bien sûr c'est un type d'habitation bien
sûr le excite tueur pas bon comme je les
dis je vous l'avais dit à au [ __ ]
[ __ ] mais jesse kia j'en peux plus
monter dans un établissement catholique
à 1000% je descende
moi je pose pour la suivante c'est le
principe à ok ayasse et j'espère qu'il
va fermer
j'ai pour vous
à
et on revient dans le hockey ok ok
j'étais caché dans un bain ok très bien
pas tout si avec ça je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient
cet endroit mon gars c'est qu'on avait
un pote faut qu'on le retrouve de suite
et un truc et monsieur je vais pas vous
mentir je trace directe
[Applaudissements]
i'm sorry excuse mais il y avait une
porte rouge à lèvres la porte 1 il
rentre il rend plus petites ont reculé
c'est un petit pis y eu ni violence anna
paquin au vainqueur 16 go fuck her seul
bien profond il ne boit pas ne boit pas
grave a jugé qu' mamadou au fond lui
pour lui il le sait voilà non équivalent
clés de son âge peut y aller
[Applaudissements]
ok hop il y avait un truc là il ya un
truc vilain sa mère va nous rattraper
là c'est moi en paix juste deux minutes
il vous plaît pensez que cette petite
chansonnette dans les communs non il ya
un truc car ils font face de moi dans
ses numéros
[Applaudissements]
oui oui on m'a pas plu et voilà les
bouts de bois mon gars c'est fini
attention tu lis que les chardons si tu
viens c'est arrête tu risques les
charbons arrête vraiment arrête
j'ai mal mais je m baré merde j'ai pu le
balajo riche tu parlais de la saison la
fenêtre
waouh
de fenech ok bah je vais vers la droite
sous le choc
là haut non non non non non
j'aime pas moins à penser comme ça par
terre j'aime pas du tout voyager vers la
fenêtre ouverte
1 la petite fenêtre ouverte dans la
salle de classe au décor normal où rien
ne va pas tout va bien un couteau voilà
on est bien ici nous sommes bien nous
sommes en paix voilà et six mois pour
voir un peu d'eux ça ne paie c'était
pour la rive on y va
normal que little big and rich plein de
jesse capendu
ça fait pas plaisir du papa ou faut
aller en jetant des choses à [ __ ] mais
a déjà suspendu aux histoires ça me
stresse qui dit comme d'abord les vidéos
ici dans le dans les souvenirs ça ne
marche pas elle y avait un monde qui à
la droite
je vous il fait quelque chose sur ce
qu'il fait mais fait quelque chose
en tout cas on va dans leur gendre par
cette porte qui bien sûr souffre parce
que c'est le chemin à prendre
et on n'est pas content de l'apprendre j
ik élevé black d'accord les photos de
campagne présidentielle oh mais mon nom
mais quel effet puis domenech faisait là
bas il ya le mont lozère ou alors venez
à moi je suis mort battus chez eux par
là du coup à rouiba il la porte s'est
ouverte maintenant [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
croix qui saigne vraiment on est là la
librairie au oui j'allais en enfonçant
la porte qu'est ce qui se passe que tu
vas faire jusqu'à trois partout avoir
entamé vers la gauche c'est hyper
profond petits morceaux bibliothèque
abuser ils ont ils ont tous 20 sur un an
avec un stock de très sale [ __ ] c'est en
titre seulement tué parmi les messieurs
pas laisser jean rampon
mais tu veux pas me laisser en paix mais
je suis choqué
par la rd chemins annexes c'est un vrai
labyrinthe 1 c'est vraiment pas cool
ben voilà on part sur un gros cul de sac
alors on va le faire sale [ __ ] dans
cette émission ça c'est une vision
[ __ ] mais c'est dur des fois je
passais une vision de foi je pense que
c'est vraiment elle
préparez vous serez meilleurs amis
attention je suis sympa je vous le dis
peut me faire confiance à 100 le
screamer ok c'est par là et il s'est
passé quoi choquer challenge et allez on
y va on y va
[ __ ] mais vraiment sur moi et c'est la
porte
voilà avec le bandage parce que bien sûr
on va se prendre 18 coups à je peux pas
mettre plus de bandage ça c'est très bas
dans ok ok il dans l'histoire des signes
moque des les buffles bloqué par des
lecteurs c'est très très beau sujet
lumière mais ce jeu avec ce fantôme elle
est beaucoup moins
j'arrive je te super pour la voir
[Musique]
ou est ce que tu es
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] [ __ ] hockey très belle
transition une fois de plus très bas
étrangers une voie plus faut que j'aille
là où quelque part là haut c'est évident
ça va de soi non on sait pas si c'est
bon retourner de l'autre côté
chopper ce bandage que je ne peux pas
l'être parce que j'ai trop de bandages
n'est jamais arrivé pas par une fois
épisode 1 je crois tu sais quand il qu
une fille timide bandage up
tel est en tout cas parle
ça commence un peu le cafard violent mon
gars ne pas me laisser tranquille deux
mondes
une pile ça ça me fait plaisir mais là
si les brûlent les ford est de les mecs
arrêtez des zombies vous êtes des êtres
quoi merde c'est les pires porte ça j'ai
pas qui a raté ses portes mais il faut
le faux le bagnard en tout cas je lui
interdit de regarder de let's play son
propre jeu ok ça changerait tout
attends fous de chaillot au [ __ ] cette
zone n'a aucun fait son auteur beaucoup
j'ai moins peur a octroyé la pièce on
impute un jour détendue la plus en plus
c'est bon oh [ __ ] pas bon au bâton
haut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est pour souffrir hockey
[Applaudissements]
cette transition bien faire damit saurai
là le truc me suis mec mais genre il me
suit mais à une d'une puissance
colossale et à mon avis c'est comme
d'hab faut aller là où il a le chemin
est là où elle est apparue la la la la
la
évidemment c'est finalement eu donc
voilà faut que la sem et comment je vais
pour la semaine c'est une bonne qu à
balai des chiottes
allez jeter ce match test mais c'est pas
genre je sais que j'étais au fond de toi
tu sais que vous voyez petit cieux ce
que vous voyez petits yeux car le père
et tout regard d'amour
gare à ceux que vous voyez le tissu
gare à ce que vous touchez le car est ce
que vous touchez petites mains car le
père et où l'arbre regarde avec amour
car est ce que vous touchez petites
mains car tout ce que tu dis petit
tout ce que tu dis petite bouche car le
père est tous là où nous regardent avec
amour gare à tout ce que tu dis que tu
as cannes film a fait soit nammi is your
breath pour se détendre ça je vais là je
vais là je me levais je me bats et
direct de près je trompé
la dose est tous ensemble tous ensemble
on peut tout ça je trouve les marches
yes et du coup je peux passer il ya une
bande du bien sûr qui s'appelle jessica
connaissons par coeur maintenant huit
ans désorienté d'accord de [ __ ] fils de
[ __ ] donc c'est le est ce que on n'est
pas est-ce que c'est pas le classique ou
du du prêtre pédophile là en fait
l'histoire
je crois que c'est ça i'll never let you
go je ne te laisserai jamais partir bah
écoute c'est ça me fait plaisir je me
dis ça ce qui est faux ce m ok eh ben
les amis je crois qu'on a assez joué
pour cet épisode a même trop je veux
pour cet épisode il était éprouvant
monde y en a je sais pas si c'est parce
que j'étais plus à fleur de peau que
d'habitude mais mais qui m'a
particulièrement mis mal quoi et bien
n'hésitez pas à aller mais s'il vous a
plu et on se retrouve les amis samedi
pour le tout dernier épisode du lait est
ce plus on sera enfin ce qui est arrivé
à l'inrs ce qui est arrivé à jesse cas
même si ça semble être la piste du
prêtre pédophile un peu voilà je vous
fais plein de bisous jeudi à trier dans
ce projet cette vidéo portez vous bien
au revoir
[Musique]